[Música]
ah
i
alguna vez se preguntaron cuántas
personas nacen por día en el mundo
alguien sabe
en el mundo nace en alrededor de 300.000
nuevas vidas bebés que seguramente serán
grandes artistas grandes médicos
psicólogos doctores maestros directivos
y seguramente grandes dirigentes del
planeta
en el quinto mes de embarazo
ya tienen un sexo asignado
inclusive un nombre
lo que muchos no saben o lo que muchos
de ustedes no saben es que un porcentaje
de esos bebés no se van a sentir
identificados con el sexo asignado al
nacer
este bebé que nació sano hermoso
todos los bebés nacen hermosos pero este
bebé es el bebé más hermoso del mundo
este bebé que nació un 23 de febrero de
1976 pesando 3 kilos 500 gramos ha
ocurrido a las 18 horas
nació en una familia común como
cualquier otra familia
pero este bebé no se sintió identificado
con el sexo en algún momento le
asignaron un al nacimiento cuando nació
no se sintió identificado con este sexo
por supuesto que nadie sabía porque a
medida que fue creciendo y a medida que
fue construyendo su vida su identidad
se supo que este niño
no era un niño este niño era una niña
que siempre había sentido su expresión
de género como una niña
y esta niña soy yo
[Aplausos]
cuentan cuentan los pueblos originarios
en américa latina se aceptaban
generalmente cinco géneros
uno de los géneros eran las mujeres
transexuales y los varones transexuales
en ese momento se llamaban mujeres dos
espíritus u hombres de 12 pies
luego de el saqueo en américa latina y
la tortura que sufrimos en toda américa
con la inquisición de la iglesia estas
cuestiones de la transexualidad se
metieron debajo de la alfombra
y qué sucedió llegado el momento
empiezan a salir otra vez estas
historias
esto está regresando a mis papás mis
papás me pudieron me pudieron
me pudieron ayudar con las herramientas
que tenían como tenían en aquel momento
con las herramientas que tenían ellos
por ahí no sabían de qué se trataba esta
cuestión de la transexualidad entonces
con estas herramientas y la poca
información que tenían que no es la
misma información que tienen hoy los
padres los abuelos la familia y los tíos
esa información que no puede seguir y
buscarla y ver qué es lo que sucede con
nuestros niños mis papás me dieron todo
por supuesto que hoy los amo
están conmigo y ellos me llaman a mí
pero en ese momento no pudieron
acompañarme entonces sentí todo el
abandono y el dolor ahí fue donde me
tuve que ir de mi casa más o menos a los
12 o 13 años y buscar mi rumbo buscar mi
destino y salir sin saber a dónde iba
y en ese interín de la vida fui
conociendo el dolor la soledad la
exclusión las cosas feas que le pueden
pasar a un adolescente un niño de 12
años imagina usted imagínense ustedes
con 12 años sola por la vida en la calle
en aquella época hoy tengo 42 lo cuento
y lo digo no hay problema 42 años y
tenía 12 13 metros de mi casa
herramientas entonces fue pasando el
tiempo fui construyendo me como mujer
fui conociendo activistas que conociendo
compañeras trans hermanas trans porque
en ese momento la única familia que
nosotras teníamos lo que yo tenía en ese
momento era otra compañera trans que le
había pasado lo mismo otra compañera que
los papás no habían podido comprender y
que no habían podido acompañarlos
acompañarlas en el tránsito de la vida y
en esta construcción que vamos haciendo
desde la niñez en la adolescencia y en
la dulce es entonces cuando estuvimos
todas juntas y comprometidas sabiendo
que nos faltaba
en argentina que nos faltaba algo en
argentina que era una ley una ley que
nos amparara o algo que nos cubriera y
algo que nos salvará que nos salvará la
vida a todas las personas trans
ahí es donde conozco a una querida
compañera que ya no está y quiero
dedicar este momento a ella ahí viene
una frase que está bárbaro
ella es claudia pía baudracco
que pase la siguiente claudia pía
baudracco una compañera que lucho que es
militante que fue militante por la ley
de identidad de género una compañera
que dijo si yo volvería a nacer trans si
volvería a nacer volvería a nacer trans
porque si soy feliz yo reivindico esta
frase de mi compañera claudia pía
baudracco fundadora de la asociación ata
y la copio y me la llevo a mí mismo y
digo si alguna vez volvería a nacer
podrían hacer trans porque si soy feliz
y así nos fuimos construyendo esta ley
sí
instalo en argentina hace 6 años atrás
la ley 26 7 43 la ley de identidad de
género esta ley que nos devuelve los
derechos a todas y todos porque
necesitábamos una ley necesitábamos una
ley que nos pudiera cuidar y que nos
devolviera estos derechos estos grandes
derechos que hoy por hoy nos permiten
tener una identidad y también nos
permite
obtener otros derechos como la vivienda
la salud la educación que es tan
importante para todos y todas muchas de
nuestras compañeras y compañeros
empezaron a terminar sus estudios hace
hace poco tiempo con 40 años también
contarles que la expectativa de vida de
todas las personas trans es de 35 a 40
años
yo tengo 42 y hoy me considero una
adulta mayor en una población hoy una
adulta mayor
no tenemos abuelas cannes con mujeres
trans del antes porque se mueren se
mueren en el camino y se mueren porque
nunca tuvimos el acompañamiento a esta
si volviera a nacer volvería a ser trans
porque si soy feliz y la broma de los
derechos porque estos derechos también
nos hacen
y podemos pensar y que podamos ir para
adelante y que podamos tener sueños y
expectativas con la siguiente
diapositiva que le quiero presentar a mi
esposa
la huelga orquesta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la vuelvo porque que también es un varón
trans y en mi compañero de vida
me emociona porque juntos pudimos vivir
la ley de género
[Aplausos]
esta ley que nos devolvió los derechos a
todos ya todas mis compañeras y
compañeros
esta ley que hizo que viniera la
argentina a devolvernos lo que el estado
quizás nos había quitado y en realidad
con mi compañero una web que también
está y qué vamos a hacer papas en algún
momento porque es lo que queremos
y vamos a hacer papá si queremos ser
papás responsables queremos ser padres
que puedan acompañar la niñez que es lo
que buscamos una niñez libre libre de
discriminación que los padres puedan
acompañar y que puedan entender a
nuestras compañeras trans que van a
nacer para poder cambiar la calidad de
vida que tienen todas las compañeras y
compañeros
hoy por hoy entonces yo hoy estoy parada
acá porque vengo a pedirle a todos
ustedes que todos los que miran por
internet y después cuando el vídeo se
distribuya
y le prestemos atención a nuestros niños
y que si nuestros niños nos manifiestan
que no se sienten identificados con el
género el ácido al nacer o con el sexo
asignado que podamos escucharlos y
escucharlas que podamos comprender qué
es lo que está pasando con nuestros
niños porque si no ocurre lo que le
sucede a todas mis otras compañeras que
hoy vemos en la calle porque no tuvieron
oportunidades porque fueron excluidas
porque fuimos destruidas y tenemos que
luchar y llegar a hacer una ley una ley
de cupo laboral trans una ley para que
nos puedan respetar y para tener un
documento a cuatro mucho pero acá
estamos y vamos a seguir luchando lo que
les vengo a pedir es que acompañemos una
niñez libre sin violencia y
discriminación muchas gracias
[Música]
i